[موسيقى]
بنك هارفارد للدماغ هو واحد من
أكبر
بنوك الأمطار في البلاد في الوقت الحالي
لدينا
ما يقرب من 5000 عينة دماغية ،
اسمي سابينا بيرجيتا ، أنا
المدير العلمي لمركز موارد أنسجة المخ في هارفارد
والذي
نسميه بمودة هارفارد دماغ
بنك
مهمتنا هي جمع
عينات الدماغ وتخزينها
وتوصيفها ثم إعادة توزيعها على
المحققين في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
ويقومون بإجراء أبحاث على الدماغ البشري وعلى
وجه الخصوص حول عدد كبير من
اضطرابات الدماغ العصبية والنفسية مثل مرض انفصام الشخصية
ثنائي القطب
والباركنسون هنتنغتون والعديد من  آخرون
، بنك الدماغ لا ينام أبدًا ، لدينا
مجموعتان من الأشخاص تحت الطلب 24 7.
لدينا نافذة زمنية محدودة للغاية من وقت وفاة
الشخص إلى الوقت الذي نحتاج إلى
الانتهاء من هذه المعالجة بالكامل ،
لذا سيكون هذا  دماغك الأول
في وقت متأخر من الليل الآن
علينا القيام بذلك في أقل من 24 ساعة
، ستجلبه مهنتنا
إلى مستشفى mclean إلى  بنك الدماغ ،
لذلك فقط ضعها هنا حتى نأخذ أنفسنا
هناك سيكون هناك تشريح جاهز
لتشريح الدماغ
[الموسيقى]
الذي يتضمن فصل نصفي
الكرة الأرضية ، يتم وضع أحد نصفي الكرة الأرضية في
محلول يحافظ
عليه الآخر  سيتم تشريح نصف الكرة الأرضية
في أقسام سميكة وسيتم
تجميدها ،
فنحن لسنا قريبين حتى من فهم
الكثير
مما نأخذه كأمر مسلم به
أفكارنا غرائزنا مشاعرنا عواطفنا
لدينا الكثير من الأسئلة ما زلنا
لا نعرف الكثير عنها  من
المحتمل أن تتم دراسة وظائف دماغنا
لفترة طويلة قادمة.
يعتبر التبرع بالدماغ بطريقة ملموسة للغاية
هدية من المعرفة ولا يمكن
القيام به
دون مساعدة العائلات والأشخاص
المستعدين للتبرع بالدماغ
[موسيقى]